All right.
So let me start again by am I hitting you
what it is that was done last time?
So if you say,
you know,
can you summarize for me in a few words,
man ideas?
So I would like to do that.
Okay.
So what I did last time was to show you how to handle Morrison in more than one
dimension.
And I picked for it,
uh,
to that.
Madison says the standard way to explain it.
Okay?
By the way,
I would like to make one recommendation if you guys have coming in a little
late,
uh,
don't worry about submitting.
The homework does come in and settle down because it's very hard to lecture with
this.
I wonder if traffic,
I do try to start a few minutes late,
but I also have to finish a few minutes early so you can go the next class.
And also people who come in early,
maybe you should try to settle,
sit in the middle part of the classroom so they're late.
Comers can come in without too much disruption.
All right,
so somebody of last time,
if you live in two dimensions or more,
you gotta use vectors to describe most things.
So the vector was typical vectors called V or arb,
something with an Arrow on it.
Most important vector is position vector that tells you where the object is.
It's got
competence,
which are x and y.
That could vary with time.
I and J are unit vectors in the x and y directions and you can deal with the
vector in one of two ways.
You can either think of it as an Arrow and imagine the Arrow are,
you can reduce it to a pair of numbers x and y.
If you want to add two vectors,
you can add the arrows by the rule I gave you are just add the components of x.
Oh the two guys to get the component of the summit.
Likewise for the y
I mentioned something of importance of increasing importance.
The only later which is that you are free to pick another set of axes,
not in the traditional x and y direction,
but it's all bleak direction.
If you do you unit vectors are call I prime and j prime,
the components,
the back of the chains.
You can imagine that if affected is viewed from an angle,
then it's competent will vary with the perspective so the competence of the
vector are not invading and characterizations of the vector betters directed
herself has a life of its own.
The components coming in the minute you pick your axes,
so it's not enough to say these are the competence of the vector.
You got to tell me.
I am working with I and j which are defined in the following manner.
I gave you a law of transformation of the components,
name leave the back that as components x and a y in one reference frame and x
prime and Aya prime.
Another reference frame.
How were the two?
They come from writing I prime and j prime in terms of I and j.
Then sticking it into the expression and identifying the new representation
somehow.
Then I told you to invert the transformation.
Some of you have some difficulty.
Maybe you didn't realize that they are just simultaneous equations that you
solve.
Normally.
If I tell you three x plus four away,
six and nine x plus six wires,
14 you know how to solve it.
It's like really the same kind of problem except that the three and four would
all be placed by signed fi and co signed fine,
but they're just some numbers and you eliminate them the same way you eliminate
them.
But I've given you a homework problem where you can,
uh,
you can try your skills.
So when you go today and look at the homework,
you'll find that besides problems from the textbook,
one extra problem that deals with all of this.
Then I gave you one other
very important example of a particle moving in the x way plan.
Excellent.
Why couldn't be whatever you like,
but I picked a very special example,
but it looked like this.
Our Times cost sine Omega t times I was art times sine Omega t.
Now you should go back and remember what we did.
If it took you a while to digest it,
I asked you to think harder.
This describe a particle that's going around in a circle.
We know it's going around in a circle because if I find the length of this
vector,
which is the x squared part was a white square part,
I just get our square at all times because science squared plus cosine squared
is one,
so we know it's moving on a circle of radius art for the Lord.
As time increases the angle
or Manga te is increasing in this fashion and Omega is called the angular
velocity and I related it to the time period,
which is the time it takes to go around the full circle by saying once you've
done a full circle,
Omega t better B two Pi.
So this new quantity Omega which may be new to you is related to the time period
which for whichever an intuitive feeling,
how long does it take to go one round in this fashion,
you're also free to write it in terms of the frequency,
the time period and frequency are reciprocals.
If it takes you one 60th of a second to go around once,
then you do it 60 times a second.
So Omega,
it's really very simple.
Quantity is related.
The frequency with which you go around the circle,
but it's multiplied by two Pi.
Why is that?
Frequency is how many times you go around and two Pi is the rate at which the
angle is being changed,
but if every revolution is where the two Pi Radians than two pie F is a number
of Radians per second,
so efforts revolutions per second and two Pi Radians per second and it's called
the angle of velocity.
The most important results from last time was that if you took this are and you
took two databases of this,
defined the acceleration
due to auto over d d square,
try to do this in your head.
If you took the two databases of this guy,
first time will become minus Omega Sine Omega t second time will become minus
Omega Square Casa,
Omega t,
otherwise it'll become minus Omegas squared times itself.
Same thing here.
The final result is the acceleration is minus Omega squared times the position.
That means the acceleration is pointing towards the center of the circle and it
has a magnitude a.
When I draw something without an Arrow,
I'm talking about the magnitude.
It just Omega squared r
yeah,
but I had shown you yesterday did the velocity and I'm sorry,
the speed of the particle as it goes around the circle is this.
Again,
you should make sure you know how to drive this.
You can do it anyway you like.
You can take one full circle.
It realized the distance traveled is to PR divided by the time and you will get
this either way.
Take the deliver to have this,
get the velocity vector and you notice this magnitude is a constant and a
constant we'll be omega are
so whichever way you do it,
you can then rewrite this as the v squared over r.
This is called the centripetal acceleration.
This is the acceleration directed toward the center and I told you this is very
important results.
Got To get this in your head and nobody to see a particle moving in a circle.
Even if it's the constant speed,
it has an Acceleration v squared over r directed towards the center.
This formula doesn't tell you which way it's pointing because it's a scalar is
not effected equation.
If you want to write it as a vector equation,
you want to write it as v squared over r minus?
Uh,
yeah.
I want to say that it's pointing in the bad action toward the center.
So sometimes what we do is we introduced a little vector here called e sub are,
I'll tell you more about it later is a bar is a vector at each point of length,
one pointing radially away from the center.
It's like the unit vector I unit directed.
I points away from the audit in the aesthetician j points every from the ideas
and the way the election er is not a fixed vector at each point.
E artists,
a different vector pointing in the radial direction of length.
One.
The advantage of introducing that guy is that if you like,
I can now write
any equation for the acceleration acid vector.
The magnitude is obese squared over r the Derek and his negative er.
So e r e s a Bot is a new entity I've introduced for convenience plays a big
role in gravitation in the coolest interaction.
Good to have a vector pointing the radial direction of length one.
That's what it is.
That's really the heart of what I did last time.
Then we did some projectile problems.
You know you should something you should know Bennett will land where it will
land with what speed it will land,
how high it will go.
I assume that those problems are not that difficult and I've given you a lot of
practice.
So now I'm going to move to the really important and central topic.
I guess you can guess what that is,
right?
We are going to talk about Newton's laws.
This is a big day in your life,
okay?
Because this is when you learned the laws symptoms,
so,
but you can understand and explain a larger number of phenomenon.
In fact,
till we do electricity and magnetism next semester,
everything's going to be based on just the loss of Newton.
It's really amazing that somebody could condense that much information into a
few,
namely three different laws that barred to be going to talk about.
So let's start.
So know your reaction may be that you know,
you've seen Newton's laws,
you've applied them in school.
I got to tell you that a idealized fairly late in life,
that more subtle than I imagined the first time.
It's one thing to plug in all the numbers and say I know the Newton's laws and I
ain't know how they work.
But uh,
as you get older and you're a lot of spare time,
you think about what you're doing,
which is something I have the luxury of doing right now.
I mean I realize this is more tricky.
I want to share some of that with you so you can fast forward and get the
understanding took me much longer to get,
that's what I'm going to emphasize more than just plugging in the numbers.
Of course we have to also know how to plug in the numbers so we can pass all the
tests.
But it's good to understand the nature of the edifice that are set up by Newton.
So first statement by Newton,
I don't feel like writing it down.
It's too long and everybody knows what the law is.
It's called the law of inertia.
Let me just say it and talk about it.
Finish it says that if you,
if a body has no forces acting on it,
then
it will remain at rest.
If it was addressed to begin with art,
if it had a velocity to begin with,
it'll maintain that velocity.
So one way to say this,
everybody will continue to remain in a state of rest or uniform motion in a
straight line.
That's another way of saying maintain velocity if it's not acted upon by a
force.
Now what makes the loss of pricing is that if I only gave you half the law,
namely everybody will remain at rest.
If it's not acted upon by a force,
you will say,
that's fine.
I accept that because here's something.
You leave it there.
It doesn't move.
It's not a big surprise.
People who are used to that from the time of Aristotle.
Yeah,
but at a startle used to think that if you want something to move that has to be
some agency making good move.
That agency,
you could call it force.
The great discovery that Galileo and Newton made is that you don't need a force
for the body to move at a constant velocity.
That
it's very clear you don't need a force.
If something is doing nothing sitting there,
the fact that you don't need a force for it to move forever,
are they given speed in a given direction?
That's not obvious because in daily life you don't see that daily life,
everything seems to come to rest unless you push it out or you pull it,
that you exert some kind of force.
But we all know that the reason things come to haul when you push them a steady
eventually some friction or drag or something that's bringing them to rest and
somehow if you could manufacture it really smooth,
frictionless surface,
that if you took a hockey puck or something and an adequate and to give it a
push in on some idealized world,
it'll travel forever.
So it's hard to realize that in the terrorist you'll situation.
But Galilee already managed to find examples where things would roll on for the
video very long time.
But nowadays if you go to outer space,
you can check for yourself that if you throw something out,
it just goes on forever without your intervention.
That is the nature of things to go at a constant velocity.
They don't need your help to do that.
Now
you have to be careful that this first law of Newton is not valid for everybody.
In fact,
I'll give you an example in your own life value to find that this law doesn't
work.
So here's the situation.
You go on an airplane and then after the usual delays plain begins to accelerate
down the runway.
I that instant,
if you leave anything on the floor,
you know it's no longer yours,
it's going to slide down and the guy in the last row is going to collect
everything,
right?
Why is that?
Because we find in that plane,
when objects are left at what we think is addressed with no external agency
acting on them,
they on slide backwards stewards that we had ended the plane that happens during
takeoff.
That doesn't happen in flight,
but it happens during takeoff so that there's an example of a person for whom
the life inertia does not work.
So this is something you guys may not have realized [inaudible] lost at.
Not for everybody.
You have to be what's called an inertial observer.
If you had an inertial observer,
then in your system of reference objects left at rest will remain addressed.
The plan that's ready to take off or is taking off is not such a system.
Yeah,
the earth seems to be a pretty good inertial system because on the ground you
leave something,
it stays there.
Okay.
Depends on what you leave.
You leave your iPod is not going to stay there for very long,
but then you can trace it to some external forces which are carrying your iPod.
But if you don't do anything,
things stay.
So here is the main point.
The point of Newton is two things in the life inertia,
which one may think is trivial.
First three velocity.
Constant velocity can be obtained for free without doing anything and there are
people for whom this is true.
For example,
in outer space,
if you're an astronaut,
you send something,
you will find it goes on forever.
Here's another thing.
If you find one inertial observer,
namely one person put home,
there's life in our show works.
I can manufacture for you an infinite number of other people for whom this is
true.
Who are these other people?
Do you know what I'm talking about?
If I give you one observable for whom the life energy is true,
I say that others put home is also true.
Yes.
Did he hear that?
Let me repeat that.
First of all,
if the life in there,
she has a valid,
for me,
it's valid for other people in the same room at rest with respect to me because
if I think is not moving,
you would think it's not moving.
That's just fine,
but suppose you are in a train and you're moving past me and you look at this
piece of chalk.
Of course everything in my room is going backwards for you,
but things which were addressed,
we'll move at a constant velocity opposite of the velocity that you have
relative to me.
So you will find that objects,
which are a constant initial velocity maintained the velocity.
So if I'm an initial observer,
another person moving relative to me at constant velocity will also be an
international observers.
Why?
Because any velocity I ascribe to a party to an to a particular object,
you will add a certain constant to it by the law of compensation of velocities,
right?
All velocities,
IC,
you will have a certain number to get the velocities according to you,
but adding a constant velocity to objects does not change the fact that those
which would maintaining constant velocity still maintain a constant velocity is
the different constant velocity and particular things that I see at at rest,
you will say,
or moving backwards at the velocity that you had a little,
to me,
things that I say are going at 50 miles per hour.
You may see that going at 80 but 50 is a constant and ab,
it's a constant.
Therefore,
it's not that there's only one fortunate family of inertial observers.
There's infinite number of them,
but they're all moving relative to each other at constant velocity.
So if the earth is the initial frame of if you go in a drain,
it lets you be at a constant velocity.
You're also initial,
but if you go on a plane with this accelerating no longer than Russia.
That's the main point.
But the point is that our inertial frame,
so reference now you must know the earth is not precisely inertial good.
The Earth has an acceleration.
So maybe can you tell me why?
I'm sure the earth has an acceleration.
Yes,
it's going around the sun.
Let's imagine it's a circular orbit that we've just shown here is an accelerated
frame of reference.
It just turns out that if you put the v squared and you put the Ar you artist 93
million miles,
you will find that acceleration is small enough for us to ignore,
but there are effects of the Er's acceleration which we'll demonstrate.
The Foucault Pendulum is one example where you can see that the earth is
rotating around its own axis and the fact that earth is going around the sun,
all of them mean it's really an odd inertia,
but it's approximately initially.
But if you go out the space nowadays it you can find truly inertial frames of
reference.
Okay,
so that's the first law.
First life you want.
If you want to say,
okay,
what's a summary of all of this summary is that constant velocity doesn't
require anything.
No.
The reason things don't have gone it,
it looks like a totality because you look around,
nothing seems to have its velocity.
If whatever,
then you say,
oh,
that's because there's a force acting on it.
It looked like a totality because you're never able to show me something that
moves forever.
A constant velocity because every time you don't find such a thing,
I give an excuse.
Emily forces acting,
but it's not a big con because you can set up experiments in free space,
far from everything where objects will in fact maintain the velocity forever.
That's a possibility and it's a useful concept on the earth because earth is
approximately inertia.
Okay,
now you come.
The second law of course,
which is the law is the law that we all memorize and learn.
And it says that if a body has an acceleration,
then you need a force.
And the relation of the forest acceleration is this thing.
No,
I have to say a few words about units.
Uh,
acceleration doesn't measure.
I in meters per second.
Square mass is measured in kilograms.
So the way to measure it forces in kilogram meters per second square.
But we get tired of saying that long expression.
So we're going to call that a Newton,
right?
Okay.
Jude invented it.
We'd call it whatever your name is,
but this is the guy who invented it.
So it's called a Newton,
usually denoted by a capital n.
So a typical problem that you may have done,
you know,
in your first pass at Newton's law,
someone tells you a force of 36 newtons is acting on a mass of whatever,
four kilograms worth the accident ration.
You divide and you find there's nine and you say,
okay,
I know what to do with Newton's laws.
That's what I want to tell you,
that it's actually more complicated than that.
Let's really look at this equation.
Take yourself back to 1600 whatever went over.
Newton was inventing this loss,
so you don't any of these laws,
you have an intuitive definition of force.
You sort of know what forces,
right?
Somebody pushes you or pulls you.
That's the force and suddenly you're told,
here is a law.
Aren't you better off in any way?
Can you do anything with this lie is what I'm asking you?
What can you do with this law?
I give you a Newton's lie and say,
good luck.
What will you do?
What does it help you predict?
You can even tell if it's true.
Here's the body that's moving,
right?
I want you to tell me yes,
Newton,
right?
How are you going to check that early?
Wanted to measure the left hand side and you want to measure that right hand
side and very equal.
Maybe you will say the lies working.
So what can you measure in this equation?
Pardon me?
All right,
so let's start with acceleration.
What's your plan?
What measuring acceleration?
If some little thing is moving,
how do you play?
What do you need to measure it?
Jeez.
Right?
But what instruments will you need to measure it?
You are supposed to really measure it.
What will you ask me for
a watch?
Yes.
And what else?
A ruler.
Okay.
Audit.
That's right.
I'm you don't mean Queen Elizabeth,
right?
You mean some long.
Very good.
Okay.
So what you really want,
a ruler may not be enough,
but maybe it's enough.
So here's the long ruler and here's this thing moving,
right?
And you asked what a Rolex.
So here's your watch stealing time.
Tell me exactly what you want to do to measure acceleration.
What do you have to do?
I want to acceleration now what will you measure?
Okay,
you go ahead.
you can try
[inaudible]
eight Ben.
I'd be at rest to begin with.
It's,
it's doing its thing.
It's going at some speed.
Yes.
Okay.
That'll give you the velocity.
Well,
did you do like distance after one sec?
Good.
So in principle,
let me repeat what he said.
He said first let it go.
Let distance take the distance time.
That gives us a velocity.
Now let it go a little more.
That gives us the velocity later.
Take the difference of the two velocities divided by the difference of the two
times and you got the acceleration.
Of course you have allowed it to move with a finite distance and a finite time.
So what you should imagine doing is making these three measurements more than
more quickly,
right?
Do you need three position regimens now,
a little later and a little later later because between the first and second you
get a velocity second,
third to get another velocity there.
Difference divided by the difference in times is going to be the acceleration.
But if you imagine making these measurements more and more and more quickly,
in the end you can measure what you can say is the acceleration.
No,
that's the meaning of the limit.
And Calculus.
You take belt bags and you take Delta t.
What's the meaning of Delta x and Delta t going to zero?
It means measured them as quickly as you can.
So in real well,
no one's going to measure it instantaneously,
but we can make the difference as small as we like it mathematically,
we can make it zero soon.
That limit,
we can measure velocity right now.
That means we can also measure the velocity slightly later and make the slightly
later come as close to right now as we want and then that ratio will give you
acceleration.
Acceleration is the easiest thing to measure.
Obesity quantities.
We all have a good intuitive feeling for what acceleration is.
So you want to test if what Newton told you is right,
you will see an object in motion.
You find a,
and you've given a certain numerical value,
10 meters per second square,
but that's not your testing the equation because you got to find both sites.
So what about the mass?
What's the mass of this object?
Anybody want to try from this section here?
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
His idea was following a,
you take a standard mass and you maybe go to a seesaw,
right?
You put the standard mass here and you put some other fellow,
the mass you're looking at there and you are just the lengths and when it
balanced,
as you can sort of tell what this masters right,
what's up,
what you at an outer space,
there's no gravity.
Then the CSO will balance.
Even if you put a potato on one side and the elephant on the other side,
you cannot tell the mass because what you are doing now is appealing to the
notion of mass as something that's related to the pull of the earth on the
object.
But Newton's laws,
you see,
you've got to go back and whiteboard everything.
You know,
if this is what you have,
there is no mention of the earth and these equations and yet the notion of
masses defined.
It's not talking about the gravitational pull of the earth on an object.
Yes.
Uh,
but do you know what the force on the body is?
We don't have to measure that either.
You agree?
We don't know what the forces,
because we are hoping to save forces is going to be an time save.
We just getting it on to measuring.
So it looks like a circular definition right now.
Yes,
yes.
Uh,
but density is mass over volume,
but we don't know the mass.
Right.
Great.
Do you do that then?
How about,
do you go ahead.
How is anyone going to give you the density of anything?
We're just asking what's the massive,
any optics we have not yet found a satisfactory answer to watch the mass up and
object.
Yes.
Are we still operating in that space?
This cannot depend on the planet earth.
Great.
Yes.
I'm sorry,
what did you just say?
You can have a spring.
Yeah.
You could have this great again,
Eh,
Oh,
uh,
objects to grab a little bit.
You don't yet.
Okay.
Let me repeat what he said.
He said,
take a spring out outer space and work,
hookup some objects to them and see how fast they move and do a comparison
that's fairly close to what I had in mind.
But it's not,
not the word.
Perfect answer.
And I just want to take some time thinking about,
yes.
Uh,
what do I learn from the period?
How
remember you have,
you cannot a peek into chapters six and seven because you've seen it before.
I'm asking you if you know somebody wrote,
apparently Shakespeare's plays for it and there's one of the rumors,
right?
Suppose Newton comes to you and says,
you know,
I have this great law but I don't want to publish it under my name,
not so I'm going to give it to you and you have got this new law,
but how are you going to sell this?
Right?
You've got to tell people how to use it and you realize it's very subtle because
the very first thing in that equation,
which is am is not yet been defined,
and he gave an answer which is fairly close,
doesn't rely on gravity,
doesn't rely on the planet.
No.
You cannot say to me,
take a force due to a spring and see what force it applies and divide by the
acceleration.
Get the mass because we haven't defined foresee that.
You got to realize that.
Let me ask you something.
How do we decide how long a meter is?
Can you tell me?
How would we know how long a meter is?
Right,
and we will call it.
First thing you got to do,
you said some of these things are not God given a meter for example,
is not deduce from anything.
Napoleon or somebody said the size of my ego is one meter.
That's it.
That's the new unit of length.
Do you take a material like silver put in a glass case and that's the meter and
that's the definition of a meter.
That's not right or wrong.
Then I asked you what is two meters and what is three meters?
We have ways of doing that,
right?
I take the meter and put it next to the meter.
That's two meters or Carter and half of use.
Some protractors and dividers encompasses.
You can split the meter into any fraction you like.
Likewise for mass,
we will take a chunk of some material and we will call it a kilogram.
So I should give you some hint.
So that kilogram I don't expect you to deduce that is a matter of convention.
Just like one second.
There's some convention we use in one meter,
some convention use.
So I'm going to give you a little help.
I'm going to give you a glass case.
And in a glass case is an entity which is one kilogram by definition.
Yes.
Then I give you another object,
elephants,
this elephant,
and I'm telling you what's the mass of the elephant?
How do you find this mass?
You've got to take the hint he gave,
I gave you a spring and an elephant.
What should we do?
Yes.
No.
Remember when we hang the elephant in outer space,
nothing's going to happen.
Right?
Okay.
And then you also do that,
the resting state,
uh,
when you say push the elephant,
you want to push it in a particular way or what do you want to do
towards the compress the spring board?
That is correct.
But you don't want to give it a definite push.
Yes.
Yeah.
Or maybe,
yeah,
maybe that's an interesting thing,
but that's correct.
You can do that too.
But uh,
let me now put you out of your suspense.
I think I've heard bits and pieces of the answer to everywhere,
so I don't want to wait till we get it word perfect.
The point is the one kilogram is a matter of convention.
We want to know what is the mass of the elephant so we can do the seesaw
experiment you said yesterday,
but the CSI pediments that acquires gravity,
so we don't want to do that so spring,
well on the other hand,
exert a force.
We don't know what the force of his spring is.
UPS assume that you're not playing by the rule because we don't know what force
it exits,
but we do know it exerts a force.
So here's what you do.
You Hook one end of the spring to a wall and you pull it from rest by some
amount and you attach the one kilogram mass to it.
Yes,
the wall,
a wall that will not move
if you look it up to any wall and every space.
Well no cheating.
No,
no,
you're,
you're right.
What can actually happen is that if you're an enormous laboratory which is made
up of an enormous object,
then you will find that you can in fact attached to the wall.
You can go out of space.
No,
it one move very much and we can,
once we know enough dynamics,
we can understand,
we can answer your question.
Does outer space even rob you of something to which you can anchor?
The spring answer is no.
You can anchor things,
do objects and outer space.
They just one act the way gravity does,
but you can nail it the wall and pull one end.
So you put pull one and we don't know what force it exerts.
Okay.
But it exerts some force.
Now I tied this one kilogram mass to it and let it go and I find the
acceleration that is the force,
which I do not know in magnitude.
Okay.
But this is the acceleration of the one kilogram mass.
Then I bring the elephants and I pulled the spring by the same amount and I find
the acceleration of the elephants.
And the denominator is obviously the massive elephant.
The force is not known,
but it's the same force.
So when they divide these two numbers,
I'm going to find a one n a e is equal to m e over m with just the one kilogram
mass.
So what we needed was some mechanism of exerting some fixed force be didn't have
to know orders of magnitude,
but the acceleration it produces on the elephant and then on the mass are in the
inverse ratio of their masses.
So if you knew this was one kilogram,
then the acceleration of the elephant,
which would be some tiny number,
maybe 100 though.
What this guy did,
the master the elephant,
is that a hundred kilograms?
No,
that is against subtleties.
Even here,
if you think harder,
you can get worried about other things.
For example,
how do I know that when I pull the spring,
the first time for the mass exhibited the same force,
but I pull the spring the second time for the elephant after all springs wear
out.
That's why you change your shock absorbers in your car after a while they don't
do the same thing.
So firstly we've got to make sure the spring exerts a fixed force every time.
Or you can say,
how am I going to check that?
I don't have the definition of force yet,
but we do know the following.
If you pull the one kilogram mass and I let it go,
it does some things,
some acceleration that or put it again by the same amount and let it go.
I do it 10 times.
If every time I get the same acceleration,
I'm convinced this is the reliable spring that is somehow producing the same
force under the same condition.
On the 11th time I pulled the Mass on,
put the elephant in of some degree of confidence I'm working with,
they're liable to spring and then I would get the massive elephant.
Why is it so important?
It's important for you guys to know that everything you write down on the
notebook or blackboard as a symbol,
it's actually a measured quantity and you should know at all times how you will
measure anything because if you don't have to mention anything,
you are doing Algebra,
trigonometry,
you are not doing physics.
So this also tells you that the mass of an object is nothing to do with
gravitation myself and object is how much it helps to accelerate in response to
your force.
Newton tells you forced this cost acceleration,
but that acceleration is not the same on different objects.
Certain objects resisted more than others.
They are set to have a bigger mass and we can be precise about how much bigger.
By saying if the acceleration of a body to given force is 10 times that of a one
kilogram mass,
then there's masses than one 10th of one kilogram.
This is how my sis can be tabulated using a spring.
So imagine then from no one we can find the mass of any object,
right?
You know now with the same spring by this comparison will find all objects now
can be attributed at mass.
Then we may from this equation,
say a certain forces acting in a given situation,
but multiplying the m times the A,
but then here's what we actually do.
Now we go back to the spring.
Okay,
you go back to the spring and we want to learn something about the spring.
We want to know how much force it exerts.
Then I pull it by a certain amount.
Now I can measure that because I pull it by one centimeter and I find the
acceleration.
It exerts on a known mass that Mtm says the forest is putting us exerting.
Then I pull it by 1.1 centimeter and I find Ama,
I find 1.2 I find Mai,
I draw a graph here of the amount by which I pull the spring versus the force it
exerts.
Yeah,
and it will typically look like this and the formula we says f equals minus Kx,
where k is called the forest constant.
Yeah.
You've got to understand
what the minus sign is doing here.
This is the force exerted by the spring.
On the mass it says,
if you pull it to the right so that x is positive.
The Springville exert a force,
which is the negative bad action.
That's where you have a minus sign
and then all springs,
we'll do something like this further out.
They can do various things.
The force may taper off.
Worse Menard be given by a straight line,
but for modest deformations every spring we'll have a linear regime in with the
forces linearly proportional to the stretching.
It also tells you that if you compress the spring compress,
it means x is now x is measured from this position where the spring is neither
compressed,
not expanded.
So x is not really the coordinator of the end point.
You got to understand that springs have a natural link,
so x is measured from that length.
If it's positive,
it means you stretched it.
If it's negative,
it means compressed and this equation is telling you if you compress it,
namely if x is negative,
f will be than positive because it's pushing you outwards.
Therefore,
what we have done now is we can take all kinds of springs and we can calibrate
the force.
They will exert under various conditions.
Namely if you pull it by so much,
that's the forest it will exert.
So I want you to think for a second about two equations.
One equation says f equals m a
other equations is f equals minus k.
X.
So what's going on?
I mean is one of them.
Newton's law and what's the other one?
Maybe F equals minus K x should be called Newton's law wise I think was maa
called Newton's law.
Then what's the meaning of this expression?
What's the difference between sayingF is minus Kx and saying f equals m a dated
saying very different things.
Yup.
Right.
Let me repeat.
F equals m a is universally true.
Independent of the nature of the force acting on a body
and then
very good.
That's the whole point.
So the cycle of Newtonian dynamics has two parts.
First one says,
if you knew the force acting on anybody without going into what costs the force,
then you may set that force equals mass times acceleration of the body.
We think of force as the cause and a as the result or the effect force causes
acceleration.
And this is the precise statement
they are.
Newton doesn't tell you what forces are going to be acting on a body in a given
situation.
If you'd leave the body alone,
maybe there's no force acting on it.
If you connect the body to a spring,
which is neither compressed,
[inaudible] extended,
there's no force acting on it.
If you pull the spring,
that is a force acting on it.
Newton is not going to come and tell you what fours the spring will exert when
it's pulled by some amount.
That is another part of your assignment.
So the physicist has to constantly find out what forces act on bodies as a
separate exercise.
In every context in which I play as a body,
I love to know what are the forces acting on it.
I've got to find them by experimenting,
by putting other bodies and seeing how they react and then finding out that's
the force that acts on the body even is placed in this or that situation.
Once you got that,
then you come back.
So in the case of a spring,
this is the law that you will do to use.
If it's something else you would have to deduce.
And other law.
For example,
we know that if a body is near the surface of the earth,
the forces of gravity and that object seems to be an times g and gs 9.8 that's
something you find out about experiment.
So every time you're finding out different force that's acting on a body with
different audits,
one says leave anybody near the year.
It feels so forced.
I know this is the right answer because if I never find the acceleration,
I find mg divided by M and they get minus g as the answer for all bodies.
By the way,
that's the very remarkable property of the gravitational force.
The cancellation of the two M's.
If you look at the electrical force,
the force of electricity,
the Proton and the electron or something,
it's not proportional to the massive either object id for abortions,
electric charge of either object.
Therefore,
when you divide by the master,
get the acceleration that a sponsor different bodies is inverse of the mass.
But gravity has the remarkable property that the pull of the earth is still
proportional.
The inertia of the object.
So there's been a divide by m m cancels and everything falls at the same rate at
the surface of the earth.
In fact,
it's a property of gravitational fields anywhere,
even in outer space,
but there is some residue will feel due to all the planets and all the stars in
the universe that the force on the body is proportional to the mass of the body.
So we need divide by the master,
get the acceleration.
You get the same answer,
everything.
Gold,
silver,
diamonds,
particles,
everything accelerates the same way in a gravitational field due to this
remarkable fact,
and this was known for a long time,
but it took Mr Einstein to figure out why nature is behaving in that fashion.
If I have some time,
I'll tell you later,
but there are two qualities which happened to be equal.
One is inertial mass,
which is how much you had your velocity to change,
how hard you resist acceleration that exists far from planets,
far from everything,
others,
gravitational mass,
which is the measurement of how much you're attracted to the earth.
There's no why.
These two attributes have to be proportional,
proportional,
and are equal by choice of units,
and you can ask is it just an accident or is it part of a big picture?
It turns out it's part of a big picture and all of dental relativities based on
this one grade equivalence of two quantities with a very different attributes.
Why should the amount by which are attracted to the earth?
The also a measure of how much you had acceleration to different features,
right,
but they happen to be the same anyway.
What physicists do is they put bodies in various circumstances and they did use
various forces.
This is the force of gravity is the force of the spring.
Here's another force you might find.
You put a chunk of wood on a table and you try to move it at constant speed.
Then you find that you have to play minimum force.
We are moving at a constant velocity.
That means the force you're applying is canceled by another force,
which has got to be the force of friction.
So forced the friction is yet another force.
Then there are other forces,
right?
You guys know there's the electrical force.
If you bring a plus charge near a plus charge,
and if my body am has a plus charge and another plus charges there,
it'll feel a forced you to that.
That's not going to be given by Newton.
So Newton did not ever tell you what the expression for forces in a given
constant that is a constant study column discovered the Columbus Law,
which is that impulse in between charges.
And nowadays we know if you go into the neutron or proton that our quirks that
are forces between the quarks and you can ask what the force that this quark
will exert and that quark at a certain separation.
There's obviously not known the Newton.
Remember Newton said f equals I may,
but didn't tell you what value f has any given contest.
He just said,
whenever there's an acceleration,
it's going to be due to some forces and it's your job to find what the forces
are and to find the forest.
What you will do is suppose somebody says,
Hey,
I've got a new force.
Every time I go near the podium,
I find I'm drawn to it.
Okay,
that's the new forest.
You know,
word gets around and we want to measure the force.
So what do I do?
I stand near this podium,
I'm drawn to it.
I cannot stop.
So I tie a spring to my back and I anchored the walk and to see how much the
spring stretches before the two forces balance.
Then I know that the Kx is equal to the force.
This is exerting at this separation and move a little closer than I find.
The stretching is a different number.
Maybe the forest is getting stronger.
That's how by a that balancing the unknown force with the known force,
odd by simply measuring my acceleration,
I say fall towards his podium and multiplying by a master,
you can find the force it exerts on me.
So it's not a sickly can,
cyclical and useless definition.
It's a very interesting interplay and that's the foundation of all our
mechanics.
So we are constantly looking for values ofF and B,
constantly looking for responses of bodies to a known force.
So he has a simple example of a complete Newtonian problem amasses attached to a
spring.
It is pulled by certain amount x and it's released.
What is it going to do?
You go to Newton.
Newton says f equals m a,
so to make it a useful in this problem,
we know the mass of this guy.
We did the comparison with the elephant or something.
A is the secondary to a vax
and for this problem when f is due to a spring,
we know the force is that by studying the spring and suddenly you have a
mathematically complete problem,
mathematically complete problem is that you can find the function x of t by
saying that the second derivative of the function is equal to minus care.
What am times the function?
Then you go to the math department and say,
please tell me what's the answer to this equation.
We don't have to worry about how you solve it,
but it's problem in mathematics and the answer will be surprised.
It's going to be oscillating back and forth and that'll come out of the of the
wash.
This is how you formulate problems.
You can formulate another problem later on.
We know about gravity,
right?
You wouldn't find south as the force of gravity acting on everything.
Here's The sun,
here's your planet,
and uh,
this incident,
the planet may be moving at that speed.
Then the acceleration of the planet is the force of gravity between the planet
and the Sun with Newton will tell you is directed towards the Sun.
And it depends on how far you are.
So depending on how far the planet is from the sun and where it's located,
you will get the lefthand side.
That's another law.
That's a law of universal gravitation.
Then again,
you will find the evolution of the planetary motion because the rate of change
of the rate of change,
a position is connected to the position.
Again,
go to the math guys and say,
what's the answer to that?
And they tell you the answer,
which will be some elliptical motion.
Okay.
By the way,
Mr. Newton did not have mad guys he could go to.
So not only did he formulate laws of gravitation,
he also invented calculus.
Then you also learn how to solve the differential equation.
For Calculus,
so he probably felt that nobody around us doing any work because all the thing
was given to this one person.
It's really amazing that what Newton did in the case of gravity was to find the
expression for this and few months or few years earlier,
they had also gotten this lie by putting the two together outcomes,
the elliptical motion of the planets.
Okay,
so we'll come back to that,
but you have to understand the structure of Newtonian mechanics or generally any
mechanics will require knowledge of the force.
Now I'm going to add one more amendment.
You don't have to write in their notebook,
but you got to remember,
maybe we'll put a little t and circle it.
Let me write it here.
F T means the total force on a body.
If there are many forces acting on a body,
the acceleration is controlled by the sun.
If I'm now working in one dimension is obvious because I'm not using any
vectors,
then you may have forces to the right forces to the left,
pushing,
pulling.
You add them all up,
algebraically,
keeping track of their sign,
and that's the total force.
That's connected to mass times acceleration can now I'll give you the third law.
The third law says that if there are two bodies then called one and to force a
one on two is minus the force of second on the first one.
This is the thing about action and reaction
and all the laws that anybody knows have this property.
So what does it require to be a successful mechanic?
To do all the mechanics problems,
you got to be good at writing down the forces,
acting on a body.
That's what is all going to boil down to.
So here's my advice to you.
Do not forget the existing forces and do not make up your own forces.
I've seen both happen and right now at this point in our course,
whenever you have a problem with that is somebody and someone says,
right,
all the forces on it,
what do you have to do is very simple.
Every force with one exception can be seen as a force due to direct contact with
the body.
He did a rope is pulling a rope is pushing it.
You're pushing it,
you're pulling it.
That is a contact on the body.
If nothing is touching the body that are no forces on it with one exception,
which is of course gravity.
Gravity's one fours that acts a body without the source of the force actually
touching it.
That's it.
Do not dry anymore forces and people do draw that forces forces in a body's
going around in a circle.
They said that some centrifugal force acting that is no such thing.
So be careful whenever that is the force,
it can be traced back to a tangible material cause which is all the time of
force of contact with the exception of gravity.
Okay?
So with that,
if you write the right forces,
uh,
you will be just fine.
You'll be able to solve all the problems we have in mechanics.
So I'm going to now start doing simple problems in mechanics.
They'll start out simple and as usual they will get progressively more
difficult.
Okay.
So let's start with the,
I would first a triumph will be motion in one d it is some object is five
kilograms and they applied 10 newtons and someone says what the acceleration and
everyone knows it.
The stand over five equals two
but now we know how have you got all the numbers that go into the very question.
How do we know tend to Zach,
oh I think you people know how we can say that with confidence.
How do we know the mass of this is five kilograms,
you know,
have you got that from an earlier experiment?
So now we know how the numbers come in.
The Algebra is of course very trivial here.
Then the next problem is little more interesting.
So he hit,
I got a three kilograms and they got two kilograms and I'm pushing with 10
newtons and I want to know what happens.
So one way is to just use your common sense and realize that if you push it this
way,
these two guys are going to move together and know intuitively that if they move
together there they will behave like an object of mass.
Five and the acceleration will again be too,
but there's another way to do this.
And I'm going to give you an out the simplest example of the other way,
which is a draw free body diagrams.
By the way.
Uh,
when I say that is 10 newtons acting this way,
you might say,
what about gravity?
What about the table?
So imagine that this is an outer space where there's no gravity for now.
So the motion is just along the x axis.
So the free body diagram,
it says you can pick any one body that you like and apply if equal Emmett do it
provided you identify all the forces acting on that body.
So we will first speak the body
mass three.
Here's the body of mastery.
What are the forces on it?
This is certainly acting on it.
Then you have to ask what other forces acting.
So here is where you have to think.
Yup.
Anybody want to guess from the last row?
What force?
Yes.
Right?
So let's give it a name,
right?
So let's pointed that way and call it f two one three.
That's the end of this guy that let's look at the other fellow.
Uh,
maybe you should complete the force acting on this one
and it tells me what it is.
Uh,
same person in the last row.
Yeah,
I know.
How big is that,
right?
So be,
I don't want to give it to many different names,
right?
Because F two,
three and after the two are equal and opposite and is showing f boot reacting to
the left.
So let me give it some other name like f then you agree this would be the CMF,
but pointing that way
and he had his mistake.
Some people,
the add to that,
the 10 newtons
is the 10 newtons acting on it because I know the 10 Newton is pushing me and
I'm going to feel it.
If I,
even if I'm here,
that would be a mistake.
That's an example of adding a force that you really shouldn't be adding.
The only force acting on this guy is this little left and that's in turn because
this guy is being pushed by the 10 Newton.
But that's not your problem.
Your problem is the only look at the forces of contact on you and that is just
as f.
Then we do f equals m a for these two guys.
But this guy f equals m a would be 10 minus F is three times a.
The other one it'll be f equals to [inaudible].
And notice I'm using the same acceleration for both.
I know that if the second mass moved faster than the first one in picked,
it is completely wrong.
And if it moves slower than the first one,
it meant it rammed into this one.
That also cannot happen.
So they're moving with the same acceleration.
So there's only one unknown a.
So once you got this,
you realize what you got to do,
right?
This equation is begging you to be added to this equation might be better plus F
and a minus f.
So you gotta do what you gotta do.
You add the two,
you get 10 equals five a and you get equals two.
Once you got eight wants to,
you can go back and realize here that F is equal before.
And so you got really four newtons.
Now we know the full story,
four newtons acting on two kilograms.
It gives you an acceleration of two on this guy.
I have 10 from the left and I have four 10 acting this way of what?
Acting that way.
That is six newtons divided by three kilograms is also acceleration of too.
This is a simple example.
Simple example of free body diagrams.
Very simple.
If you can do this,
you can do most of the problems you will run into.
Yes,
don't add stuff that's not there.
That's all you have to be careful about and the stuff that people tend to add
sometimes is to keep drawing the 10 Newton is acting on that.
Okay,
now here's another radiation.
Radiation looks like this.
I got three kilograms and I have a rope and I got two kilograms and I pulled
this guy with 10 newtons.
What's going to happen?
I gained your comments since downs.
You look,
you're pulling something was effective.
Mass seems to be five.
The answer to this too.
Let's get that uh,
systematically by using free body diagrams.
Now that it really three bodies here,
block one,
block two and the rope connecting right now in all these examples,
this rope
is assumed to be massless.
Uh,
we know there is no thing called the massless role,
but most ropes have a mass which may be negligible compared to the two blocks
you're pulling.
So we'll take the idealized limit where the mass of the rope is zero.
So here's the deal.
Three kilogram is being pulled by the rope on the right with a force that I'm
going to call t,
which stands for attention.
The rope is being pulled backwards by this guy,
the t.
And what is the forest on the other side?
What should that be?
Was that t and why is it they definitely tea and not something else?
What would happen if it's something else?
Good.
Well,
if it was greater
one snap,
but something else will be a problem.
Yes.
Not only faster.
What it'd be is acceleration.
If the two forces don't cancel,
you have a net force.
What are we going to divide by to get the acceleration?
Zero.
Right?
So massless body cannot have a net force on it because the acceleration of the
rope cannot be infinite.
In fact,
it has to be some finite number,
which is the acceleration of either of these two guys.
So massless bodies will always have like a massless role,
equal and opposite forces on the two ends and that is called the tension on the
road.
So when you say the rope is under tension being pulled from both sides by a
certain force,
the tension is not zero just because this d and that he canceled.
It's true.
The net force is zero but doesn't mean you can ignore it,
right?
Suppose you are being pulled by my favorite animals.
The elephants from both sides.
By equal force,
you don't find any consolation in the fact that these forces add up to zero,
right?
Yeah.
You feel the pain.
That pain is what we,
the gentleman doesn't agree.
One of you guys nodding your head.
You feel the pain.
You agree?
Okay.
That force is called the tension.
So you and I would get asked in the problem what the tension on the road you're
looking for that equal and opposite forces acting at two ends of the rope,
so we don't know what it is.
We'll give it a name,
but by linking that t to that tea,
you can also figure it out.
The same team must be accepted on this one by Newton's third law because if this
block is the only one that could be pulling this rope,
but t therefore the ropes will be pulling the block with the other direction.
Then I got 10 newtons here.
Now you can do f equals m a for the three different objects.
There's nothing to do here because the forces are zero.
The masters zero,
it doesn't tell you anything.
The first one tells you t equals three.
A other one tells you 10 minus t
equals to a
no.
Again,
we know what to do.
We add these numbers and we get 10 equals five a net for refined egg once to,
once you find a equals two you find teak or the six.
The tension on the rope is six newtons.
Yeah,
no,
this is very important because when you buy a rope,
they'll tell you how much attention it can take before it'll snap.
And if your plan is to accelerate a three kilogram mass with an acceleration of
two meters per second,
you better have a rope that can furnish that for us and we can take the tension
of six newtons.
Alright,
now for the,
uh,
whoa.
Okay.
I'm going to give the last class of problem with this pretty interesting,
which is what happens to you when you're in an elevator.
So he had us a weighing machine and that's you
standing on the elevator and we're going to ask,
oh,
what's the needle showing a different times?
First take the case and the elevators and the ground floor of some building and
completely addressed.
Then let's look at the spring.
The spring is getting squashed because you're pushing down in the float is
pushing up,
pushing down with the weight mg and the Floridas gotta be pushing up with Wade
empty because the spring is not going anywhere.
So it's bring us being pushed
by AMG here and AMG here.
Therefore it'll compress by an I'm on x,
which is equaled mg divided by the force constant of the spring.
By the way,
that's the second thing people may not have realized.
Even in the case of this spring,
when you pull it,
if you pull it to the right by some force,
remember the wall is pulling to the left with the same force says brings her,
always pushed or pulled on either side with the same force.
We focused on one because we are paying for it,
but the wall is doing the opposite.
We don't pay any attention to that,
but you cannot have a spring pull only at one site because then it'll that
accelerate with infinite acceleration in that direction.
So this spring is getting squashed on either side and it will squash.
They said no more.
Next,
that depends on your mass and that x will be turned into a motion of a needle
and that'll read your mass.
Now,
what happens if the elevator is accelerating upwards with an acceleration?
A,
that's the question.
No.
The way I analyze it is I say,
if I look at me and I write the forces on me that is empty acting down.
Let me use w as the symbol to represent the force exerted by the spring.
W minus AMG is m a that is f equals m.
A.
When I was not accelerating the,
everything was addressed.
Mia was zero,
W was AMG and w was the reading on the needle.
But if I'm accelerating the force exerted by the spring and therefore the
needle,
the weighing machine reads is m times g plus a.
It means when you're accelerating upwards as the elevator picks up speed,
the reading on the spring,
we'll be more than you will feel heavy.
You feel heavy and it reads more because the poor spring not only has to support
you from falling to the floor but also accelerate.
You countered to what gravity wants to do.
That's why it is g plus h so you picked up some speed,
then you're coasting along at a steady speed than a ad drops out any way.
Your normal self.
As you come to the top of the building,
the elevator has to decelerate so that it loses its positive philosophy and
comes to rest.
So able to be negative and W in fact will be less than mg.
So you will feel weightless for a short time or do you feel your way this
little?
Then you come to rest and the opposite happens on the way down.
Let me just briefly look at the ride on the way down.
As you start at the top and go down,
your acceleration is negative.
Nobody got to keep track of the sign of acceleration.
So if you're picking up speed towards the ground,
a is negative.
So it'd be deeply say,
but ace a negative number.
So let me write it as g minus the absolute value of a,
and you can see that if a was equal to g,
you're downward acceleration is that of gravity.
Namely the cable has snapped in the elevator.
Then you don't feel any weight,
you don't feel any weight because you wait as the above the opposition.
You get the falling through the floor.
But the floor is giving way and you're just falling freely.
You feel weightless.
So it's wrong to think that you feel weightless because you escape the pull of
gravity.
We all know,
even the falling elevator,
you've definitely not as the pull of gravity.
It's going to catch up with you in a few seconds.
Like westbend and outer space.
You know,
as orbiting the earth.
People that are always floating around in these space stations,
they have not skipped the pull of gravity either.
They just stopped fighting it.
If you guys get the pull of gravity,
your spaceship will be off,
won't be orbiting the earth.
So anyway,
I will return to this next time.
So do your problems.
Now.
There's quite a few problems.
You should start them right away.